when they make a movie out of this
podcast tom hanks will play you
yeah that's right you're a hero hey
wasn't he nice on the podcast
oh i love him so isn't he the best he's
the nicest guy and people always say
that
i'm telling you i've known him since
1988 and uh
i've i've spent uh you know when you add
up
all the time that i've but i've been
around him uh i've
uh only see him be a gracious really
nice fascinating guy
very funny very smart do you know that
when you guys were talking about world
war ii
i would never do this i would never
interrupt but i wanted to talk
and just just i loved talking about that
stuff and i was
just just drooling while you guys were
talking about that
yeah no i'm glad you didn't jump in no i
know you're glad
no you know what i mean you know what i
mean yeah i would never i would never
it's
not yeah too i'm just saying like but i
could have listened to you guys go on
for hours
about that no when two icons of film are
talking you don't
just want to let them go you're an icon
of film yeah
i was cut out of the conehead's movie
what were you uh conehead in the
background
that's a true story i was out here
remove you lauren mike lauren michaels
wanted it was one he was talking to me
about doing the late night show and
and he went to have a meeting with me
and then he just was like
just i'll meet you at paramount or
whatever and i went okay and i went to
paramount and he went just
listen you're a paramount anyway just be
in the background of this coneheads
movie
we're making the conants movie because
the best time to make a movie about the
coneheads is uh
25 years after it's it's been a huge hit
on television
but anyway he said just be in the
background and i went uh
you don't say no to lauren and i went
okay and then and then when you know
when you're done doing that we'll we'll
talk
and so uh the next thing you know i'm in
a trailer and they're putting a big
cone on my head and
then i walk out and those things are
ridiculous they're really heavy
and you can't maneuver and i'm tall
anyway i'm 6'4 but the cone made me
about seven
four oh my seven five and then
uh i i was like oh man this is
really painful i'm just gonna lie down
and this person with a headset and a
clipboard said don't lie down you can't
lie down
you have to keep standing until your
scene is shot because you'll ruin the
cone
and i'm literally it's like a crowd
scene and i'm in the background you
don't even know it's me and i'm thinking
i just
was here to talk to lauren get over
there and wait
and in 40 minutes we'll throw some
ground chuck your way
and so i'm i'm waiting and then i'm in
the background and i go okay action
literally there's i mean i'm so far from
the camera
that i can't even see the camera and i
hear you know dan aykroyd say
yes blindart no blender and jane curtin
goes blue
and they go and cut okay we'll do that
one more time
in six hours everyone leave no one lie
down
and uh then finally i shot the scene of
course they never use that scene